für mein empfinden mit große
gewalttätigkeiten das heißt es denn
deutschland gemeinsam machen ist aber
keinen satz dieses gewusel macht mich
kirill
du wirst langsam ungeduldig gut wir auch
wieder belohnt so sagt egal wer
spitzenkandidatin ist
gerichtsurteile deckeln keine mieten
applaus und nette worte erhöhen kein
gehalt gilt
türe nicht verkehrt klatschen
wenn ich mich von der linken liste und
nur diesen sport würde ich gleich mal
wählen schon der alles völlig richtig
die steuern einkommen und vermögen
gerecht verteilt fragmentiert ich weiß
gar nicht wo ich in gruppen soll jungen
menschen mehr gibt
[Musik]
ist damit gemeint
sind natürlich widersprüche ohne ende
auf der einen seite sagen sie wer tore
hilft nichts auf der anderen seite
fordern sie das bett was es respekt
anderes als sozusagen ihre korrekte
gefühle vom respekt kann ich auch meinem
leben nichts einfach nur mit uns hier
leben wollen eine gesellschaft die mit
gefühlt also alles rot das ist ja so
richtig bei der linken und dann
zwischendurch dieses
erfreut sich großer sich um gute arbeit
zu schaffen wer ständig angst vor
kündigung und armut hat kann keine gute
arbeit das ist natürlich alles richtig
wirtschaft
um das wettrennen mit der klimakrise zu
gewinnen unsere gesehen die zu ihrer
krise wird auch nicht mit frist band
folgen
[Musik]
ich komme nicht mehr mit wo gott jetzt
das kind auch noch nicht
aber es soll nicht so genau hinschauen
weil dann vechta total in sich zusammen
gerufen
[Musik]
komplett alarmbereitschaft gerade ja das
war
ziemlich schnell ziemlich fragmentiert
ich möchte jetzt eigentlich erst mal
eine folge musikantenstadl oder so was
sehen denn ich bin aufgewühlt also der
spot der linken hat einen guten rhythmus
hat einen guten ton und so ist es
vielleicht von all den spots der der am
besten gemacht ist trotzdem gefällt mir
dieses treibende der musik dieses bild
im bild prinzip fest vor allem als
hauptsächliches organisationsprinzip
ihrer nachrichten und ihrer gelder
bemühen nicht weil ich das gefühl habe
es ist so nett gegenpropaganda mittels
werden dann diese dinge dieses schlimmen
dinge gezeigt
shirt von ting also mufflons die sich
sind das mufflon mufflons die sich die
köpfe ein rennen patronen geld es wird
geklatscht ich fange so ein bisschen
mixed signals denn das wollen sie
eigentlich weg haben kämpfen ja also ich
bin atemlos nach diesem spot und
scheint schaltung was zu gehen das ist
alles kein atom der link wirkt auf den
zweiten blick ein bisschen abstoßend in
seiner arroganz und in seiner verloren